[Music]
we happy few is a game packed with
twists turns and a well-crafted campaign
offers an eerie insight into an
alternative diamond shoot the single
player story can last anywhere up to 25
hours and beyond but there's a quick way
to skip the entire game in under just 2
minutes the others who like wasting 40
pounds can simply start the game and do
the following after beginning heart this
story the player will come across an
article referencing the character's
brother Percy due to the pain of this
could cause Arthur is given a choice to
either take a joy pill and remove the
sadness or to refuse one whilst most
gamers will probably instinctively fight
against the system and begin the game by
avoiding the pill it's still a nice
choice to offer them that is reminiscent
of alternate game endings such as Arkham
City and Far Cry 4 to me this is a great
reference to the film the matrix in
which the character neo was offered the
choice of taking the blue or red pill
and journeying outside of the world that
has been pulled over his eyes or
remaining in it the game is packed with
Easter eggs like this and it's
definitely an interesting journey
through a drug-fueled society that
relies on short-term highs to make it
through a mundane day-to-day life so
have you played through me happy fuse
campaign yet or did you take the easy
way out comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and subscribe to my
channel make sure you check out my
website Definition core at UK for more
movie games and TV insights thanks again
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you